[Musik]
jahr für jahr beginnen mehr als 100.000
menschen ein neues leben in der schweiz
was bringt sie dazu ihre heimat zu
verlassen und in der schweiz neu zu
beginnen und werden wie in der schweiz
ihr glück finden
[Musik]
wir haben menschen aus vier ländern bei
ihrem neuanfang in der schweiz begleitet
was bisher geschah
[Musik]
mit 50 hat sich die portugiesin lisa
entschieden in der schweiz ein neues
leben zu beginnen
[Musik]
in ilanz arbeitet sie in einem alters-
und pflegeheim
[Musik]
als kind hat sie bereits in deutschland
gelebt und die sprache gelernt
da sind immer hoch und runter hoch und
runter
[Gelächter]
im tessin gefällt mir lugano besonders
gut die menschen dort denn wie die
beiden schwestern und drazan haben
zusammen mit ihrer familie aus syrien
bietet siegen ein neues zuhause gefunden
vor zwei jahren floh die familie über
das mittelmeer in die schweiz
inzwischen wurde ihr asylgesuch
anerkannt ich werde niemals vergessen
was wir seit dem ausbruch des krieges
leben allah sei dank
und danke den schweizern dass sie uns
aufgenommen haben die inder raul und
mega stehen kurz vor ihrem umzug in die
schweiz
das müssen wir in zürich auch machen
raul ist erfolgreicher manager in indien
jetzt tolle zürich als die i o eine
schweizer firma leiten
auch seine frau bereitet sich auf ihr
neues leben vor einmal die managerin
gibt einiges auf ich werde sogar selber
putzen lassen
bisher wurden die beiden mit ihrer
tochter bei rauls eltern in der schweiz
werden sie dann ohne ihre hilfe
auskommen müssen die franzosen jury und
fabia haben in der schweiz problemlos
eine arbeit gefunden und dazu in der tat
die wohnung ihrer träume
juli arbeitet als projektleiterin bei
nestlé fabia ist ingenieur nun gilt es
den papierkram zu erledigen müssen wir
danach bern noch nein das können sie
hier erledigen
[Musik]
sasha son wanderland was ist das da kann
man karten anschauen
wir wandern ja zum kredit
da werden wir ordentlich wachsen müssen
mehr als sie gewohnt sind dass endlich
die natur war einer der gründe für die
beiden in die schweiz zu kommen
jetzt ist es soweit ihre erste große
wanderung steht an
vielleicht sehen wir dort sogar einen
steinbock wirklich sagen der wasser
mitnehmen und einen regen schritte
zentrale ihre aufenthaltsbewilligung
haben sie bereits erhalten hier endlich
eine saubere weste so sauber wie meine
sonnenbrille in neu delhi rückte abflug
von rauen er seit letzte vorbereitungen
zu treffen
guten tag das hier möchte ich waschen
leiden sind mehrere pullover
die schweiz ist eines der teuersten
länder der welt alles ist dort
wesentlich teurer als hier in indien
hier kostet so was einen frankfurt ich
denke mal das wird in der schweiz das
vier- bis siebenfache sein
ich werde man ja sehen
ich bin erstmal froh dass die sachen
gewaschen werden kleider waschen nicht
nicht meine stärke
weil wir zunächst einige wochen alleine
in der schweiz verbringen und die
ankunft seiner frau und seiner tochter
vorbereiten
ich hätte gerne ein paar energie am main
voller magie ich kaufe ein paar macken
die esse ich hier in indien seit meiner
kindheit
das ist eine schnelle mahlzeit und sie
wird mich an zu hause erinnern
das ist wichtig wenn ich in der schweiz
ankomme werde ich mich an viel neues
gewöhnen müssen
da ist es gut wenn man ein paar sachen
von zuhause hat das passt doch das ist
von einem schweizer herstellers und wenn
wir das an den indischen markt anpassen
können kann ich mich auch an die schweiz
anpassen
manche denken indien ist ein land voller
schlangenbeschwörer andere denken in der
schweiz gibt es nichts vernünftiges zu
essen
ich gehe lieber auf nummer sicher
die franzosen sind auf ihrer
langersehnten ersten wanderung in der
schweiz betonblöcke das vernichten falls
ein baum umfällt oder straßensperre die
schweiz gibt den franzosen rätsel auf
vielleicht das werk eines vergessenen
künstlers keine ahnung das müssen wir
mal in ruhe nachschauen unter der woche
so früh aufzustehen und jetzt noch am
wochenende
ich habe das gefühl wir sind schon ewig
gelaufen
dabei dachte ich dass wir so gegen acht
oben sind und plötzlich ist die
schweizer natur von der sie schon so
viel gehört haben
zum greifen nah schau mal da
ich hab ich noch nie so nah gesehen mit
dem fernglas 30 den fotoapparat draußen
aber ist er weg naja man kann ja auch
einfach den moment erleben
[Musik]
verschränkt ein traum wird wahr bereits
auf ihrer ersten wanderung erleben die
franzosen die schönheiten der schweizer
natur das ist richtig mystisch hier so
lange da keine ritter auftauchen kann
nicht sehen dass da rechts ist da sollte
eine felsspalte sein ansehen
mit joachim russland ein loch gut man
sieht nicht mal den boden
[Musik]
die natur ist wunderschön hier
das dumme ist dass wir von der
gepriesenen tollen aussicht nicht sehen
schade naja ein anderes man vielleicht
mal während der woche frei nehmen wenn
das wetter gut ist
[Musik]
heute wäre einfach die ideale
bei liedern scheint die sonne
wie verbringt ihren verein tag im
freibad alleine als sie von einem jahr
in die schweiz kam hoffte sie auch eine
neue liebe fürs leben zu finden
ich glaub ich muss lernen zu warten
inneren inneren frieden den ich jetzt
langsam auch weil ich habe jetzt keine
lust wechseln und wechseln und wechseln
und aufbauen und machen und sie dann
arbeitsstelle aufbauen ich habe jetzt
keine lust mehr
und das war auch nicht der sinn der
sache jetzt die schweiz zu kommen ich
wollte eben nicht als die kommen die
ständig auf der suche nach den anderen
platte mehr verdient und ich nein ich
wollte was ich wollte und ich will was
aufbauen
könntest du dir vorstellen hier als zu
warten die pflichten aber nicht alleine
dann bist du schon einen schönen
angenehmen so passenden partner finden
vielleicht kommt er noch dank ihrer
arbeit kann dieser ihre beiden söhne und
ihrer mutter in portugal finanziell
unterstützen
doch die große liebe ließ bisher auf
sich warten
[Musik]
lisa gibt die hoffnung aber nicht auf
für die muslime hat der ramadan begonnen
und mit ihm eine reihe von ritualen
so zum beispiel das fasten bis zum
sonnenuntergang
es wird gekocht aber noch das nicht
gegessen werden probieren es streng
verboten
dafür ist es dann wie eine belohnung
wenn wir nach sonnenuntergang endlich
essen dürfen die als versuchen die zeit
bis zum essen rumzukriegen so gut es
geht jeder auf seine art
[Musik]
toller form
er sagt das ist gut so einmal pro jahr
das ist eine gute sache ist zum beispiel
die raucher die tasten einen monat lang
nur noch abend brauchen sagte ramadan
steht für frieden und nächstenliebe
das finde ich auch sehr gut
ramadan aus modellen die app auf dem
smartphone gibt die erlaubnis zum essen
wenn die sonne verschwunden ist beginnt
für die familie die zeit der fröhlichen
gemeinsamkeit auch in der schweiz
das sind die momente in denen den als
ihre vom krieg versprengten verwandten
besonders fielen während des ramadan ist
die familie auch im gebiet vereint in
diesem moment des gebets bedecken auch
die mädchen ihre haare eigentlich die
gegen das kopftuch so navigieren sie
zwischen zwei welten
[Musik]
in neu delhi ist es zeit zu fahren
das ist ein dampfkochtopf sowas hat hier
jeder hof dieses modell ist speziell für
induktionsherde in der schweiz oder das
wird hart für ihn
wie will er denn in der schweiz alleine
wright kochen und mehr kann er sowieso
nicht
ich habe da meine zweifel
kannst du das mal wegräumen den rest
packen wir später ein
jetzt wird er ein paar monate lang auf
sich selbst gestellt sein und wir werden
hier ohne ihn sein
das macht mich traurig aber wir helfen
ihnen ja bald hinterher reisen
jetzt ist es also soweit dass eltern
werden bald alleine in der wohnung
zurück bleiben
das ist gut für seine karriere das ist
okay für mich
zuletzt hat er drei jahre am stück hier
mit uns zusammen gelebt mit seiner frau
und unsere süßen enkelkind
juni
für bohlen geht ein kapitel seines
lebens zu ende
ich bin viel gereist
ich war fast die hälfte meiner
arbeitszeit
aber wenn ich jetzt meinen schrank
lehrräume dann wird mir bewusst dass ich
wirklich weg ich habe fast mein ganzes
leben hier verbracht werden
das ist schwer es tut mir auch leid für
meine eltern sie werden alleine
zurückbleiben
klar sie werden uns besuchen kommen aber
das ist nicht das gleiche
ja so ist das leben
es ist die zeit der fußball
europameisterschaft
das finale ist gerade in gang nach ihrer
stellt sich bereit ich lieder zum
kapitän der portugiesen zu kommen
es gibt auch total in frankreich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die portugiesischen fans treffen sich in
einem saal in flims um gemeinsam das
finale zu erleben
[Applaus]
die rund 10.000 portugiesen sind die
größte einwanderer gruppe in graubünden
fiebern mit ihrem team
am ende dann die erlösung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
alleine in der masse lieber teilt ihre
emotionen mit ihren söhnen in portugal
endlich haben wir es ihnen gezeigt
ich bin hier in einem kleinen dorf alles
portugiesen
dabei muss man hier ohne familie ohne
verwandte und ziemlich einer feier zu
halten bieten allein
sicherlich ist das ganze bereue aber das
wäre gut dass man gerade so hätte ich
jetzt schnell nach port kathrin können
auf wiedersehen
ich weiß nicht wo außerdem portugal
[Musik]
du hast ein geschenk bekam der abend
voraus abflug in die schweiz zusammen
mit mega hat er die familie für eine
abschiedsparty in einem nobel-hotel in
neu delhi eingeladen
das sind alles menschen mit denen ich
aufgewachsen will
es berührt mich wie jetzt zu verlassen
immerhin sie wollen uns alle besucher
zum thema schweiz hat ja jeder etwas zu
sagen ich war schon zwei oder dreimal
dort einmal sogar für fünf tage ein
wunderschönes land am meisten war ich
von der pünktlichkeit der züge
beeindruckt aber warum ist alles so
teuer
ich habe gehört die fahren zum einkaufen
nach deutschland war ist er billiger ist
hast du ein paar tipps für mich das wird
super es ist wunderschön dort das
einzige problem ist das essen
warum kann zurückkommen doch brot und
käse
du kannst noch so ich habe eine bekannte
die sagt genf sei eher langweilig aber
das gute an der schweiz ist das ist
super für kinder ist die schweiz
generell warum alleine wegen der
sauberen luft hier neu delhi wächst
seine tochter in einer der schmutzigsten
städte der welt auf und sie wird
deutschland firma
eine menge sprachen das ist nicht wie in
die ferien fahren
wir werden für mindestens drei jahre
dort hinziehen
ich freue mich und gleichzeitig habe ich
an
zürich neuchâtel empfangen verdient sie
ihren ersten besuch in der neuen wohnung
es ist eine tante von lilly
[Musik]
wir haben eingekauft sie ließ tante lebt
seit ihrer jugend in der schweiz und ist
mit einem schweizer verheiratet
das ist sehr gut
[Musik]
wir finden uns noch gar nicht richtig zu
hause wir sind so oft in frankreich am
wochenende richtig hier nach einer
hochzeit wird ruhiger werden hoffentlich
auch feuer wohl die hochzeit der beiden
soll in frankreich stattfinden
wir waren in der bourgogne um alles
vorzubereiten
wir haben auch nach einem guten weg
gesucht das war gar nicht so einfach
hier wollen wir nicht weil er mit
wahrheit nie drauf gekommen bin konnte
ich auch nicht aber als es gesagt hat
wollte ich ihn nicht mehr die hochzeit
gefällt durch den die autos ist nicht
schlecht stimmt wie auf einer postkarte
auch wenn du das nicht jeden abend zu
genießen wirst wenn man in der zeitung
liest was sonst so los ist in der welt
kann man wirklich froh sein hier zu sein
sie hat sechs mal eine balance verloren
hier fühlt man sich sicher genau das
haben wir gesucht
ihr habt mich mal ein auto oder wie
kommt ihr denn nach frankreich fahren
nach genf und von dort aus der
mitfahrzentrale weiteres manko einkaufen
gehen wir hier zu fuß und sonst nehmen
wir den zucker hier gibt es überall zu
mit dem auto das ist nervig ich habe es
einmal gemacht nie wieder
die gäste kennen die schweiz im gespräch
geben sie einen teil ihrer erfahrung an
die neulinge weiter es gibt hier ein
dorf
da wird geschossen aus 300 metern
entfernung mit einem gewehr auf teller
auf eine zielscheibe in 300 metern
hier laufen irgendwie alle mit ihren
gewehren rund neulich habe ich im zug
soldaten gesehen mit sturmgewehr und das
militär ist kein spielchen drei wochen
lang nur männer erst im büro und dann
plötzlich die flöten in der hand flöten
nennst du die gewehre
na klar flöten
[Musik]
wie viele flüchtlingsfamilien wurde auch
die familie als chef auf ihrer flucht
vor dem krieg auseinander gerissen
besonders mutter aber er ist in gedanken
oft bei ihrer ältesten tochter
sie hat den sprung nach europa nicht
geschafft sie sind von syrien aus nach
libyen gegangen wir in den libanon
wir haben uns getrennt wir in eine
richtung wie in die andere
wir haben sie seit drei jahren müssen
wir gesehen
ich weiß gar nicht wie sie sich
verändert hat
[Musik]
ich würde mir sehr wünschen dass meine
tochter farah auch bei uns ist ich kenne
nicht mal meine enkelkinder
nichts ist bei uns so wertvoll wie die
eigenen enkel
[Musik]
ihr traum die verlorene tochter in die
schweiz holen
deshalb haben sie einen antrag auf
familiennachzug gestellt über freunde
haben sie kontakt zu einem anwalt
bekommen der ehrenamtlich flüchtlingen
hilft ihm wollen sie besuchen um das
dossier voranzubringen
also wo fangen wir an
wer erzählt mir die geschichte wir haben
eine große schwester die im libyen
hängen geblieben ist
das ist schwierig für sie hat zwei
kinder und erwartet
und sie ist 19 jahre alt
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
habt ihr einen antrag gestellt damit sie
in die schweiz kommen können
habt ihr schon eine antwort ein brief
die eltern sprechen kein italienisch die
kinder müssen das schwierige dossier
übersetzen
der antrag wurde abgelehnt hat die
bereits über 18 weil sie nicht mehr
minderjährig war als ihr den antrag
gestellt habe das ist hier die regel
die beiden mädchen können den anwalt
überzeugen
gut die situation scheint mir recht klar
eure geschichte bewegt mich und ich
möchte euch helfen
wir werden tun was sie können
ihr besuch beim anwalt gibt der familie
neuer hoffnung vielleicht hätte er auch
die schwester in die schweiz schaffen
[Musik]
in indien ist der moment von raus
abreise gekommen dass hier gebe ich ihn
mit auf den weg wenn er das essen im
flugzeug nicht mag oder heimweh hat kann
er das essen 90 an mich erinnert ich
gehe auf nummer sicher dass alle koffer
da sind
die verabschiedung verläuft nach
indischem ritual zuerst empfängt raúl
den segen seiner mutter anschließend
berührt er als zeichen des aspekt die
füße seiner eltern
[Musik]
der gott ganesha soll mögliche
hindernisse auf der reise aus dem weg
räumen
kannst du mir bitte die tür offen halten
wäre es vorsicht
[Musik]
das geht schon
ich bin sehr traurig erst jetzt sind mir
bewusst dass wir wirklich gelingen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lass uns noch mal alle in den arm nehmen
noch einmal alle mit dir
kamine
[Musik]
auch lisa tritt eine lange reise an
während ihrer sommerferien will sie ihre
beiden söhne und ihre mutter im norden
portugals besuchen um zu sparen nimmt
sie eine komplizierte anreise in kauf
jeder franken fällt den leader
unterstützt sowohl ihre mutter wie auch
ihre beiden söhne finanziell
ein sohn studiert die andere ist
arbeitslos wie jeder vierte unter
25-jährige und portugal
ich war jetzt eigentlich zwei dreimal im
jahr nach port anstrengend also für
meine börse anstrengend auch für die
seele
die kinder die betagte mutter lisa weiß
es wird keine einfache rolle
anfang mai soll ja hier bin ich jetzt
kümmere ich mich um eine menge zu
erläutern muss die eigentlich mich auch
brauchen würde dies alleine
also ich schon eine kontroverse
situation am anfang fühlte ich mich sind
und zugang zu entschuldigen wenn man
besser nachdenkt hat einzig den anderen
ja nichts zu tun
[Applaus]
er kommt aber zurück in zwei monaten
nein in zwei wochen zum ersten mal seit
ihrer flucht kommen rahman und raser in
einem jugendlager in den genuss von
ferien herzchen nicht weinen
[Musik]
mama hat mir noch gesagt sie für und
brav sein und nicht fluchen zuhause
streiten wir uns fast die ganze zeit
aber meistens gibt rasen dann gleich
wieder nach stimmt doch gar nicht du
gibst du kannst ja nicht sein
den koffer platz gleich noch nie waren
die beiden so lange von ihren eltern
getrennt und wenn sie nicht mehr
zurückkommen
ich bin jetzt schon traurig dass sie
wegfahren
ich kann einfach nicht ohne wie sein ich
finde sie super meine mädchen schwer
einige freunde kommen auch mit syrien
laptop unter uns um die ecke
das ferienlager wird speziell für kinder
organisiert deren eltern sich viele
nicht leisten können
habt ihr die karte von der
krankenversicherung
habt ihr euch alle von euren familien
verabschiedet
[Musik]
sie kommen ja wieder
für ihr lieben haben geely und verlieren
die schweiz gewählt
den bund fürs leben beschließen sie
jedoch in ihrer alten heimat im süden
frankreichs
in japan und indonesien sowie fusionen
entwicklungspolitik um die frage die ihr
euch jeden morgen stellt wie kann ich
den anderen glücklich machen
ich habe anfang juli als rechtmäßig
angetrauten ehefrau
ich verspreche dir treu zu sein und dich
zu lieben bis ans ende meines lebens
empfange dich verliert als rechtmäßig
angetrauten ehemann
ich verspreche dir treu zu sein und dich
zu lieben bis ans ende meines lebens
so erkläre ich euch hiermit rechtmäßig
zu mann und frau
die dürft euch jetzt küssen
[Applaus]
ein neuer lebensabschnitt ein neues
zuhause
jetzt haben sie nur noch einen wunsch
doch den wollen sie nicht verraten noch
nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schön war
die letzte etappe von dieser reise per
bus geht es von porto nach braga im
norden des landes
[Musik]
der markt damit jetzt ab der eltern und
der jüngere war der hund beim vater zu
hause warten schon die probleme
hast du schon herausgefunden was los
weißt du der parkplatz ganz nah an der
mauer
da ist ein großer riss in der mauer und
das ist ein ziemliches problem ich habe
erst heute morgen bemerkt dass das ein
echtes problem ist trotz allem lieder
freut sich in ihrem alten zuhause zu
sein
das aparte man hat sie zusammen mit
ihrem ex mann gekauft
hier haben sie ihre kinder großgezogen
nach der scheidung hat lisa die wohnung
übernommen noch heute zahlt sie jeden
monat raten ab das parkett ist ja total
abgelaufen
bei eduardo ist es das gleiche also ich
werde sicher nicht für die
instandsetzung aufkommen
unterwasser fleck an der decke
ab
[Musik]
nein
bis 21
wer meint meine arbeit
und das passiert in der nächsten folge
von gerührt die schweiz wie ein wanderer
führer uhr beginnt ein neues leben in
der schweiz
mein gott das ist ja totenstill hier
das neue jetzt muss hier alleine
klarkommen ich habe gehört das ist ein
typisches produkt aus der schweiz
[Musik]
lisa erlebt in ihrer alten heimat ein
wechselbad der gefühle
meine mutter die wahl verliert was ist
demenz im alter ihre söhne kommen
alleine klar aber wie leben sie mit der
entscheidung ihrer mutter weg von ihnen
ins ausland ziehen
sie hatte einfach keine andere wahl
auf seiner hochzeit muss ich fabia
einige sprüche gefallen lassen wieso
findest du die schweiz plötzlich total
ich habe meinen ersten lohn erhalten
juli geht voll und ganz in ihren neuen
job in der schweiz auf papier jedoch
stellt sich große fragen über seine
zukunft
ich war vorher eine gute stelle zu
finden inzwischen finde ich sie ziemlich
langweilig also hatte ich die augen
offen
[Musik]
bauern und rasern erleben die ersten
ferien ihres lebens das anstrengend die
vergangenheit reist mit in die berge
feiere krieg da hat man nur die hoffnung
am leben zu bleiben
[Musik]
euro